[Musique]
le jour se lève sur Winnipeg après une
nuit glaciale que beaucoup ont passé
dans la rue l'itinérance est devenu une
véritable crise dans la capitale
manitobaine et elle touche les
autochtones de manière disproportionnée
mais pour 22 personnes il y a maintenant
un peu d'espoir un début de solutions
qui accueille des pensionnaires depuis
quelques semaines
dans chaque unité un lit une télévision
une salle de bain et une cuisinette
l'essentiel pour repartir à zéro
s'habituer à avoir un toit
ce projet est le fruit de consultation
avec des personnes itinérantes explique
Mélissa Stone c'est leur création
ancienne infirmière de rue elle connaît
l'étendue des besoins Winnipeg la preuve
à peine ouvert nikkinak a déjà une liste
d'attente
en plus des mini maison un espace commun
ou les résidents ont accès à une variété
de services de transition
est spirituel axé sur les rituels
autochtones
mais aussi de l'aide alimentaire
financière et médicales ici les
pensionnaires peuvent se reconstruire
sans la pression de compte à rebours
la construction avant d'arriver à
nikkinak en quelques semaines à peine il
a remarqué une différence chez les
pensionnaires certains ont déjà trouvé
un emploi et il semble tous plus heureux
dit-il
de Nicky NAC voudrait que son projet
servent d'exemples dans le reste du pays
mais sans financement en permanence son
avenir n'est pas assuré
[Musique]
et c'est 22 mini maisons ne représentent
qu'une goutte d'eau dans l'océan des
besoins
[Musique]